do you think he needs to have a body to
start to um
notice the signs of life and to develop
the kind of system that's able
to reason perceive the world in the way
that an agi should and act in the world
so should we be thinking about robots or
can this be achieved in a purely digital
so i have a clear opinion on that and
that's that no it does not need to be
embodied in the physical world where you
could say most of my career is about
making simulated virtual worlds you know
in games or virtual reality and so on a
fundamental level i believe that you can
make a simulated environment that
provides much of the value of what the
real environment does and restricting
yourself to
operating at real time in the physical
world with physical objects i think is
an enormous handicap i mean that's one
of the real lessons driven home by all
my aerospace work is that i've you know
reality is a [ __ ] in so many ways there
we're dealing with all the mechanical
components like everything fails
murphy's law even if you've done it
right before on your fifth one it might
come out differently
so yeah i think that anybody that
that is all in on the embodied aspect of
it they are tying a huge weight to their
ankles and i think that
i i would
almost count them out anybody that's
making that a cornerstone of their
belief about it i would almost write
them off as being worried about them
getting to agi first
i was very surprised that elon's big on
the uh the humanoid robots i mean like
the nasa robonaut stuff was always
almost a gag line like what are you
doing people well that's very
interesting because i he has a very
pragmatic view of that that's just the
um a way to solve a particular problem
in a factory now i do think that once
you have an agi robotic bodies humanoid
bodies are going to be enormously
valuable i just don't think they're
helpful getting to agi well he has a
very sort of practical view which i
disagree with and i argue with him but
it's a practical view that there's
you know you could transfer the the
problem of driving to the problem of
uh robotic manipulation because so much
of it is perception
it's perception in action and it's just
a different context and so you can apply
all the same kind of data engine
learning processes to a different
environment and so why not apply to the
human robot environment but
um
i think
i do think that there's a certain magic
to the embodied robot
that may be the thing that finally
convinces people yes but again i don't
really care that much about convincing
people you know the the world that i'm
looking towards is you know you i you
you go to the website and say i want
five frank one a's to you know to work
on my team today and they all spin up
and they start showing up in your zoom
meetings
to push to push back but also to agree
with you but first to push back i do
think you need to convince people
for them to welcome that thing into your
into their life
i think there's enough businesses that
operate on an objective kind of profit
loss sort of basis that i mean if you
look at how many things
again talking about the the world as an
evolutionary space there when you do
have free markets and you have
entrepreneurs uh you're gonna have
people that are gonna be willing to go
out and try whatever crazy things and
when it proves to be beneficial you know
there's fast followers in all sorts of
places
yeah and and you're saying that i mean
you know quake in vr
is a kind of embodiment but just in a
digital world and if if you're able to
demonstrate if you're able to do
something productive in that kind of
digital
reality
uh
then then agi doesn't need to have a
body yeah it's like one of the really
practical technical questions that i
kind of keep arguing with myself over if
you're doing a training and learning and
you've got like you can watch sesame
street you can play master system games
or something is it enough to have just a
video feed that that is that video
coming in or should it literally be on a
virtual tv set in a virtual room even if
it's you know a simple room just to have
that sense of you're looking at a 2d
projection on a screen versus having the
screen beam directly into your retinas
and i
you know i think it's possible to maybe
get past some of these signs of life of
things with the uh just kind of
projected directly into the receptor
fields but eventually for more uh kind
of human
emotional connection for things probably
having some vr room with a lot of
screens in it for the ai to be learning
in is likely helpful it may be a world
of different ai's interacting with each
other self-play i do think is one of the
critical things where socialization-wise
one of the other limitations i set for
myself thinking about these is i i need
something that is at least potentially
real time because i want it's nice you
can always slow down time you can run on
a subscale system and and test an
algorithm at some lower level and if
you've got extra horsepower running it
faster than real time is a great thing
but i want to be able to i am to have
the ais either socially interact with
each other or critically with actual
people your sort of child development
psychiatrist that comes in and interacts
and does the the good boy bad boy sort
of thing i as they're going through and
exploring different things and it's nice
to
i come back to the value of constraints
in a lot of ways and if i say well one
of my constraints is real time operation
i mean it might still be a huge data
center full of computers but it should
be able to interact on a zoom meeting
with people and that's how you also do
start convincing people even if it's not
a robot body moving around which
eventually gets to irrefutable levels
but if you can go ahead and not just
type back and forth to a gpt bot on
something but you're literally talking
to them in an embodied over zoom form
and working through problems with them
or exploring situations having
conversations that are fully stateful
and learned i think that
i think that that's a valuable thing so
i do keep all of my eyes on on things
that can be implemented within sort of
that 30 frames per second i
kind of work and i think that's feasible
do you think the most compelling
experience is that first will be
for pleasure or for business as they ask
in airports
so uh meaning is is it if it's
interacting with
ai agents will it be
sort of uh like friends
um
entertainment
almost like a therapist or whatever that
kind of interaction or is it in the
business setting something like you said
brainstorming different ideas
so
this is all a different formulation of
kind of a touring test or the spirit of
the original touring test where do you
think the biggest
benefit will first come so it's going to
start off hugely expensive i mean you're
going to
if
we're still all guessing about what
compute is going to be necessary i fall
on the side of i don't think you run the
numbers and you're like 86 billion
neurons 100 trillion synapses i don't
think those all need to be weights i
don't think we need models that are
quite that big evaluated quite that
often you know i base that on we've
we've got reasonable estimates of what
some parts of the brain do we don't have
the we don't have the neocortex formula
but we kind of get some of the other
sensory processing and it doesn't feel
like we need to we can simulate that in
computers for less weights but still
it's probably going to be thousands of
gpus to be running uh you know a human
level agi depending on how it's
implemented that might give you sort of
a clan of 128 kind of run-in batch uh
people depending on whether their
sparsity in the way the the weights and
things are set up if it is a reasonably
dense thing then just the memory
bandwidth trade-offs means you get 128
of them at the same time and either it's
all feeding together learning in
parallel or kind of all running together
uh kind of talking to a bunch of people
but still if you've got thousands of
gpus
necessary to run these things it's going
to be kind of expensive where it might
start off i'm a thousand dollars an hour
for your you know even post development
or something for that which would be
something that you would only use for a
business if you know something where you
think they're going to help you make a
strategic decision or point out
something super important but i also am
completely confident that we will have
another
factor of a thousand in cost performance
increase in agi type calculations uh not
in general computing necessarily but
there's so much more that we can do with
packaging making those right trade-offs
all those same types of things that in
the couple next couple decades 1000x
easy and then you're down to a dollar an
hour
and
then you're kind of like well i should
have an entourage of ais that are you
know following me around helping me out
on anything that i want them to do
that's one interesting trajectory but
i'll i'll i'll push back because i have
um
so uh for in that case if you want to
pay thousands of dollars
it should actually provide some value
i think it's easier
for cheaper to provide
to provide value via a dumb ai
uh
that will take us towards agi to just
have a friend
i think there's an ocean of loneliness
in the world and i think an effective
friend that doesn't have to be perfect
that doesn't have to be intelligent that
has to be empathic
having emotional intelligence having
ability to remember things
having the ability to listen most of us
don't listen to each other one of the
things that love
and when you care about somebody when
you love somebody is when you listen and
that
is something we treasure about each
other and and
if an ai can do that kind of thing
i think that
provides a huge amount of value and very
importantly
provides value in its ability to listen
and understand
versus provide really good advice i
think providing really good advice
is very difficult next level step that
would um
i think it's just easier to to do
companionship yeah i wouldn't disagree i
mean i think that there's very few
things that i would argue can't be
reduced to a uh some kind of a narrow ai
i think we can do trillion dollars of
value easily and all the things that can
be done there and a lot of it can be
done with smoke and mirrors without
having to go the whole thing i mean
there's going to be the equivalent of
the doom uh
the doom version for the agi that's not
really agi it's all smoke and mirrors
but it happens to do enough valuable
things that it's enormously uh useful
and valuable to people but at some point
you do want to get to the point where
you have the fully general thing and you
stop making bespoke specialized systems
for each thing and you wind up
start using the higher level language
instead of writing everything in
assembly language
what about consciousness
the c word do what do you think that's
fundamental
to solving agi or is it a quirk of human
cognition
so i think most of the arguments about
consciousness don't have a whole lot of
merit uh i think that consciousness is
kind of
the way the brain feels when it's
operating
yes and this idea that
you know i do generally subscribe to
sort of the pandemonium theories of
consciousness where there's all these
things bubbling around and i think of
them as kind of slightly randomized
sparse distributed memory bit strings of
things that are kind of happening
recalling different associative memories
and eventually you get some level of
consensus and it bubbles up to the point
of being a conscious thought there and
the little bits of stochasticity that
are sitting on in i in this as it cycles
between different things and recalls
different memory that's largely our
imagination and creativity um so i don't
think there's anything deeply magical
about it certainly not symbolic i think
it is generally the flow of these uh
associations drawn up with stochatic
stochastic noise overlaid on top of them
i think so much of that is like it
depends on what you happen to have in
your field of view as some other thought
was occurring to you that overlay and
blend into the next key that queries
your memory for things and that kind of
determines how you know how your chain
of consciousness goes so that's kind of
the qualia the subjective experience of
it is not
is not essential for intelligence i
think so i don't think there's anything
really important there what about some
other human qualities like fear of
mortality and stuff like that like um
the fact that this ride ends
is that
is that important like you you me you
know we talk so much about this
conversation about the value of
deadlines and constraints
um do you think that's important for
intelligence actually a super
interesting angle that that i don't
usually take on that about has death
being a deadline that forces you to make
better decisions because i have heard
people talk about how if you have
immortality people are going to stop
stop trying and working on things
because they've got all the time in the
world
i am but i would say that
i don't expect it to be a super critical
thing that i that a sense of mortality
and death impending death is necessary
there because those are things that they
do wind up providing reward signals to
us and we will be in control of the
reward signals and there there will have
to be something fundamental that causes
that engenders curiosity and goal
setting and all of that i am something
is going to play in there at the
reward level
i am you know whether it's positive or
negative or both
i don't have any strong opinions on
exactly what it's going to be i but
that's that type of thing where
i doubt
that might be one of those half dozen
key things that has to be sorted out on
exactly what the master reward that's
the meta reward over all of the
uh the local task specific rewards have
to be that could be that big negative
reward of death
maybe not death but ability to walk away
from an interaction so
it bothers me when people treat ai
systems like servants
so it doesn't bother me but i mean it
it's it really is drawing the line
between what an ai system could be it's
limiting the possibility of an asset
could be is treating them as justice
tools now that's of course for from a
narrow ai perspective there's so many
uh problems that narrow ai could solve
just like you said
as
in in its form of a tool but it could
also be a being
which is much more than a tool and to be
a to become a being you have to respect
that thing for being a being
and for that it has to be able to have
um
to make his own decisions to walk away
to say i had enough of you i would like
to break up with you now
uh you've not treated me well and i
would like to move on so uh i think that
actually that choice
to end things
so i i have
a couple of things on that so on the one
hand uh it is kind of disturbing when
you see people being like people that
are mean to robots and you know mean to
alexa whatever and that seems to speak
badly about humanity but there's also
the exact opposite side of that where
you have so many people that imbue
humanity in inanimate objects or things
that are toys or that are are relatively
limited so i think there may even be
more more danger about people putting
more emotional investment into a lot of
these proto ais in different ways yeah
um and then the ai would manipulate that
but but as far as like the ai ethnic
sides of things
i
really stay away from any of those
discussions or even really thinking
about it it's similar with the safety
things where i think it's just premature
and there's a certain class of people
that enjoy thinking about impractical
things things are not in the world and
you know of pragmatic effect around you
and i think that
begin again because i don't think
there's going to be a fast take off i
think we actually will have time to have
these debates when we know the shape of
what we're debating
and some people do take a principled
approach that they think it's going to
go too fast that you really do need to
get ahead of it that you need to be
thinking about this because we have slow
processes of coming to any kind of
consensuses or even coming up with ideas
about this
and
maybe that's i maybe that's true
i wouldn't put any of my money or
funding into something like that because
i don't think it's a problem yet and i
think that we will have these signs of
life when when we've got our learning
disabled toddler we should really start
talking about some of the safety and
ethics issues but probably not before
then can you elaborate briefly about why
you don't think there'll be a fast take
off is there some deep intuition you
have about it does it because it's
grounded in the physical world or why
yeah so
it is my belief that we're going to
start off with something that requires
thousands of gpus and i i don't know if
you've tried to go get a thousand gpu
instance on a cloud anytime recently but
these are not things that you can just
go spin up hundreds of
there are real challenges to i mean
these things are going to take data
centers and data centers take years to
build you know and the last few years
we've seen a few of them kind of coming
up going in different places their big
engineering efforts you can hear people
bemoan about the fact that i you know oh
the the network was wired all wrong and
it took them a month to go unwire it and
rewire it the right way these aren't
things that you can just magic into
existence
and the ideas of
like the old tropes about it's going to
escape onto the internet and take over
other systems there's the fast takeoff
ones are clearly nonsense because you
just can't open tcp connections above a
certain rate no matter how smart you are
even if you have perfect hacking ability
that take over the world in an instant
sort of thing just isn't plausible at
all and even if you had access to all of
the resources these are going to be
specialized systems where you're going
to wind up with something that is
architected around exactly this chip
with this interconnect and it's not just
going to be able to be plopped somewhere
else now interestingly it is going to be
something that the entire
um
the entire code for all of it will
easily fit on a thumb drive that's total
spy movie thriller sorts of things where
you could have hey we cracked the secret
to agi and it fits on this thumb drive
and anyone could steal it now they're
still gonna have to build the right data
center to deploy it and have the right
kind of life experience curriculum to
take it up to the point where it's
valuable but the real core of it the the
magic that's gonna happen there is going
to be very small you know it's again
tens of thousands of lines of code not
millions of lines of code it is possible
to imagine a world as you mentioned in
the spy thriller
view if it's
if it's just a few lines of code
we can imagine a world where the surface
of computation is growing maybe growing
exponentially
meaning
there's you know the ref the
refrigerators start getting a gpu
and uh just
every first of all the smartphones the
billions of smartphones but maybe if
there
become
highways through which code can spread
across the entirety of the computation
surface
then you don't
any longer have to book aws
um
gpus real fundamental issues there when
you start getting down to taking an
actual problem and putting it on an
abstract machine like that
that has not worked out well in practice
and the idea that
there was always
like it's always been easy to come up
with ways to get com compute faster to
say more flops or more more gigaops or
whatever there that's usually the easy
part but you then have interconnect and
then memory for what goes into it and
when you talk about saying well cell
phones well you're limited to like a 5g
connection or something on that and if
you say how
if you take your your calculation and
you factor it across a million cell
phones instead of a thousand gpus in a
warehouse you might be able to have some
kind of a substrate like that but it
could be operating then at 1 1000 the
speed and so yes you could get you could
have an agi working there but it
wouldn't be a real-time agi it would be
something that is operating at really a
snail's pace you know much much slower
than kind of human level thought for
things yeah i'm not worried about that
problem you're transferring the problem
into the interconnect the communication
the shared memory
the the collective intelligence aspect
of it which is extremely difficult as
well i mean it's back to the very
earliest days of super computers you
still have the the balance between
bandwidth storage and computation and
sometimes they're easier to get one or
the other but it's been remarkably
constant across all those years that you
still need all three
you